[Musique]
nous est arrivé déjà une fois de penser
à cette perte de familles qui n'ont pas
la possibilité d'offrir un repas par
jour à leurs familles à leurs enfants
sur comment il essayait d'expliquer à
ses enfants qui comprennent peut-être
pas tous que aujourd'hui demain après
demain ça serait difficile d'avoir un
repas dans la journée je suis content
malick dia bâ je suis conseiller du
président de la république togolaise et
je fais partie de ces personnes pour qui
ce genre de situation et vécu parfois à
travers des dossiers à travers des
documents mais qui a pour engagement et
pour obligation de penser aussi et de
mettre en oeuvre les actions qui
permettent de combattre la pauvreté la
grande pauvreté partager la prospérité
partager la prospérité
oui nous le pouvons quand j'ai eu
l'opportunité de vous entretenir cet
après midi j'ai choisi de vous parler de
comment pouvons-nous partager la
prospérité
création de richesse pour laquelle nous
devons tous les jours pour aller au
travail pour générer des revenus
d'abord parce que en tant qu'africains
nous sommes dans des environnements
extrêmement complexe extrêmement variés
contrairement à ce que les gens pensent
et qui ne sont pas exactement les mêmes
donc cette question est particulièrement
importante pour nous autres africains
ensuite parce que cette question couvent
énormément d'aspects et concerne à peu
près tout le monde concerne le monde
entier en réalité et se manifeste à
travers des différentes déséquilibre
qu'on peut constater quand on observe le
monde en particulier
ce qui frappe quand on observe
l'évolution du monde sait que l'extrême
pauvreté a tendance à reculer un peu
partout et malheureusement pas dans
notre continent destin pauvreté a
tendance au mieux à se stabiliser et au
pire a augmenté et on parle de la très
grande pauvreté pas d'une pauvreté qui
est supportable et de la très grande
pauvreté quelque chose de très difficile
à supporter qui affectent la vie des
gens et qui rend les gens extrêmement
vulnérables extrêmement vulnérable à
tous et en particulier aux chocs
notamment les chocs climatiques parce
que nous sommes vulnérables parce que
nous sommes vulnérables sont encore plus
ouverts à ces chocs là ce qui est
important de se dire c'est que
l'africain potentiel énorme en termes de
croissance démographique
mais cette croissance démographique si
elles ne trouvent pas de réponses dans
ce que nous produisons elle devient un
danger pour le continent elle devient
une difficulté pour nous développer
il est important de se rendre compte qu
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde
extrêmement déséquilibrée entre les pays
riches et les pays pauvres entre les
personnes qui ont des très grands
revenus et ceux qui ont des moins de
revenus plus ou moins important entre
les hommes et les femmes
quand on voit les écarts de salaires
qu'on constate entre les ruraux et les
urbains et en ceux qui sont connectés et
ceux qui ne sont pas connectés
ces écarts nous devons travailler dessus
de manière collective
les contrastes et les déséquilibres que
nous constatons dans notre monde ont
tendance à faiblir le lien social qui
nous lie ont tendance à nous rendre plus
faibles elles ont tendance à créer des
tensions entre nous et pas seulement
dans les pays comme le nôtre même
partout à travers le monde et ceci
génère des difficultés sociales
politiques et parfois conduisent à des
déchirements beaucoup plus important que
ce que nous voyons ici dans nos pays
quand bien même nous avons l'impression
que nous sommes accablés par la pauvreté
si nous prenons le cas du togo nous
vivons ces difficultés au quotidien à
travers un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui ne progresse pas
suffisamment à notre goût la fracture
numérique les difficultés à se soigner
les difficultés à avoir une éducation
qui correspond au monde du travail
auquel nous devons faire face les
difficultés avoir suffisamment d'énergie
tout simplement pour avancer dans la
société
ces réalités ne sont pas une façon de
nous accabler ou de dire que nous sommes
dans une situation où nous ne pouvons
pas avancer nous avons nous avons cette
difficulté tout en sachant que nous
sommes dans des environnements qui sont
historiquement culturellement et qui
sont marquées par des comptes est
extrêmement difficile
cela est évoqué tout au long des
différentes présentations nous sommes
soumis à un certain nombre de situations
sociales politiques qui nous conduisent
à une situation de développement qui
n'est pas suffisant pour partager la
prospérité
quand on prend l'afrique de l'ouest la
zone ue mois le togo malgré ces
indicateurs que vous avez sous les yeux
est un des pays les plus performants de
en termes d'alphabétisation en termes de
couverture sociale et en termes de
capacité à insérer les jeunes qui
viennent sur le marché du travail
alors pourquoi malgré cela on a
l'impression que la prospérité n'est pas
suffisamment partagée
on a cette impression parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire toucher du doigt
les individus partout où ils se trouvent
de la croissance économique et des
actions de développement qui sont menées
nous sommes là pour vous proposer des
leviers pour pouvoir réaliser ces
actions ne développe pas et n'est
rapprocher des populations à travers
quatre leviers
le premier de ces leviers qui repose en
fait sur ce que nous appelons là
le partage le déplacement de la
production
qu'est ce que c'est que déplacer la
nous avons longtemps imaginé des modèles
de développement basé sur une production
centralisée dans la vivent dans des
localités des mégapoles qui en fait ont
pour objectif de créer de la richesse
qui sera ensuite redistribué à travers
différents circuits extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement cher aux autres
qui ne sont pas dans la vie et qui ne
sont pas dans les centres de décision
dans les centres de pouvoir on se rend
compte que le mécanisme de déplacement
de cette richesse produite est lui-même
tellement cher qu'en réalité il vaut
mieux pour que ça n 1 bat qu'il faut
pour que nous touchions le maximum de
gens il faut qu'on arrive à amener les
facteurs de production vers les gens et
non produire et déplacé ce que nous
avons produit un exemple très simple
c'est par rapport à l'énergie solaire
pendant longtemps l'accès à
l'électricité s'est fait à travers la
connexion au réseau central qui existe
et qui est un réseau qui est compliqué
et pour lequel une connexion au réseau
de la compagnie électrique national peut
prendre énormément de temps à ce qu'il
faut mettre des poteaux il faut mettre
des câbles et cetera et cetera
aujourd'hui avec l'énergie solaire
vous avez un carton vous avez un kit
solaire en quelques minutes suite à
votre demande vous êtes servis en
électricité en énergie la production se
déplace vers vous l'objectif c'est
d'arriver à partager la richesse en
déplaçant la production en emmenant
cette production jusque dans les
villages jusque dans les maisons sans un
processus extrêmement complexe et
extrêmement lourd et des coûts afférents
très important que l'état ne peut pas
supporter pour tout le monde en tout cas
pas
le deuxième levier c'est s'appuyer sur
la technologie
cela a été dit tout au long des
présentations la technologie pour nous
autres africains
c'est en quelque sorte le facteur
miracle le facteur qui va nous permettre
de réaliser des sauts qualitatifs
extrêmement important quand on prend
l'exemple de la big data des données les
données dans le domaine social sont le
moyen qu'on a aujourd'hui de cibler
mieux les actions de l'état et surtout
de les diriger vers ceux qui en ont
vraiment besoin
et encore plus de les diriger vers ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin ne l'a dirigé
vers ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
les données nous permettent d'avoir des
cartographies de savoir qui a besoin de
quoi à quel endroit qui a déjà bénéficié
de tels programmes et ensuite d'arriver
à lui apporter ce qu'il faut à lui
apporter le service public à lui
apporter les services de santé à lui
apporter les services scolaires à lui
apporter le prof de mathématiques qui
manque parce que il ya des collèges dans
lesquelles il manque des profs dont les
dans les domaines scientifiques
la technologie c'est aussi la
possibilité de créer un compte bancaire
sans être obligé de se rendre à la
banque est aujourd'hui dans nos pays
dans notre pays on offre cette
possibilité là de façon simple vous
n'êtes pas obligé de vous déplacer vers
la banque
vous avez un compte épargne qui est
rémunéré par la poste pour faire pouët
précis et pour faire un peu de publicité
la pause
un poste est pas un compte épargne
rémunéré avec un taux et que qui vous
permet d'ouvrir le compte sur votre
téléphone mobile sans vous déplacer
aujourd'hui avec cette technologie là
les barrières tombent et notre enjeu
c'est de faire tomber ces barrières
un peu partout dans nos pays de faire en
sorte que le rural qui démarre une
activité économique
c'est qu'il peut créer un compte
bancaire sans être obligé de faire tout
le process de la carte nationale
d'identité avant d'avoir son compte
bancaire dans une banque au
fonctionnement classique le troisième
devient s'est autonomisée et
responsabiliser les deux premiers
facteurs portent sur des facteurs
relativement technique relativement un
peu lié à la technologie et aux
évolutions on peut constater autonomiser
les responsabiliser c'est en fait donner
la main à ceux qui sont concernés donné
la mer aux populations être capable être
capable de leur montrer comment se
prendre en charge dans le cadre du
processus de développement
aujourd'hui le développement ne peut
plus ne doit plus se concevoir comme un
prêt penser quelque part dans un bureau
avec des documents très bien écrit bien
documenté qui sont apportées au niveau
des populations avec toute une série de
projets qui vont marcher c'est vrai mais
qui vont marcher le temps où le projet
est là et quand le projet sera parti le
projet va là les effets du projet vont
s'arrêter
mais comment faire pour pérenniser ce
que nous faisons parce qu'on l'a vu dans
le monde localité on a des actions qui
sont menées pendant un certain nombre
d'années et au bout d'un certain temps
la formule qu'on entend ben ils sont
partis ils sont partis et ça s'est
arrêté il faut pas que ça s'arrête parce
que le développement ne peut pas
s'arrêter là croissance démographique ne
s'arrête pas la population a besoin de
continuer et c'est en donnant la
capacité aux populations de s'approprier
ces mécanismes de développement que nous
arrivons à pérenniser à faire en sorte
que ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui peut
continuer demain mais pas parce que nous
revenons parce que nous ne pouvons pas
ir partout mais parce que les
populations ont compris et ont pris la
main sur leur destin est le dernier des
leviers dont nous allons parler et le
levier le plus important je pense le
levier sur lequel nous devons tous
travailler et qui est en fait la
bienveillance la bienveillance qui est
en fait le fait d'avoir une pensée
positive vis-à-vis d'autres y de penser
que l'autre quand il mène une action
vis-à-vis de vous quand une main d'une
action en général est mû par une bonne
fois une volonté d'avancer une volonté
de faire quelque chose pour lui-même
pour sa famille pour sa communauté pour
son pays et au fond sans cette
bienveillance le tissu social dont nous
parlons qui nous unit tous et qui nous
permet de construire quelque chose pour
les générations à venir
nous n'y arriverons pas tout simplement
il n'ya pas d'autre voie
nous n'avons pas d'autre issue entre
nous que de développer cette
bienveillance et que de développer cette
valeur qui au fond nous permettra de
garder le lien social de combler le
grand écart qui se crée entre les
différentes couches de la société
parce que nous croyons que la cohésion
et le moyen principal d'arriver à
partager la prospérité que nous avons
devons créer la prospérité
mais nous devons aussi la partager en
développant la bienveillance et je sais
que vous ici chacun en ayant une
attention pour ceux qui vous entourent
vous pourrez à dire entre hank lady gear
les problèmes des gens et pouvoir les
aider
c'est aussi cette bienveillance là je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]